5. uncomfortable career truths that
developers don't want to hear
big salaries fancy companies what's not
to love from the outside it seems like
developers have it easy we get paid well
to do a highly specific job usually we
go home at 5 pm and don't work weekends
often we have a supportive team culture
at work developers build a software
that's running the world
take a closer look though and you'll
realize that developers career comes
with its own challenges like any other
job it's not perfect let's talk about
the reality of software engineer take
off those rose-colored glasses and
acknowledge some hard truths number one
social skills are better than technical
skills the reality is that being
successful in this career requires
communication a lot of it at certain
points you'll have to collaborate with
teammates project managers and clients
on features you'll have to ask on help
on things you don't understand even more
important being well liked is how you
keep your job and gain new opportunities
in your career it doesn't matter how
good of a developer you are you could
write thousands of lines of code per day
but if you don't communicate about it
effectively you won't get ahead number
two you're never an expert cliche alert
software is constantly changing people
love to point out the counter factual to
me Fortune dubs are making a ton of
money right now because they're so rare
they're so rare because their jobs are
going away to work in this field
successfully you'll have to keep up with
the changes however you also need to
avoid chasing every shiny new tool in
software development expertise is a bit
of Illusion don't get me wrong there are
expert developers but they're not
experts because of how much they know
about a particular technology and set
their experts because of how many
Technologies they've seen come and go it
takes years of consistency to get grade
if you think you're an expert then
that's a sure sign you're probably not
experts know how much they don't know
number three the job is often boring the
reality is that software engineering can
be boring you spend hours staring at
screen fixing bugs implementing features
or refactoring someone else's old code a
large portion of software out there is
just crud apps with simple functionality
most days the task at hand won't be that
interesting seniority helps but it also
makes the problems harder now you're
scaling a cred app or finding much more
challenging bug sometimes it's quite
frustrating actually every day comes
with its own little annoyances staying
engaged and curious is hard work
number four it's a young man's game
overwhelmingly developers are young men
outside the expected groups age race and
gender your path will be more difficult
the difficult truth is to acknowledge
it's wrong but it's real the terrible
thing is that the lack of diversity
hurts us all the engineers building the
software aren't diverse then the
products they create are missing the
prospective of other groups with the
power software holds in today's world
that's kind of scary within this truth
there's another truth about software
that goes often on a knowledge ageism
everybody becomes old So eventually
you'll be forced out into early
retirement or consulting or opted into
management or a very few small architect
roles number five there's no such thing
as perfect developers like clean
complete Solutions software is almost
never clean nor complete you'll
constantly be frustrated by technical
debt lack of documentation poor test or
something else that's missing from your
code base no code will ever be perfect
if you strive for Perfection you'll work
yourself to the Bone and you'll never
achieve it good enough that's the Mantra
most developers who have been around to
the block a few times they know that the
good features ship today is better than
the perfect feature ship the month from
now requirements change so quickly
anyway you could spend hours on a
perfect solution only to have the
customer request something totally
different
this of course is the motivation behind
the agile Manifesto but more personally
it could mean that the work is
constantly kind of messy there aren't
clear unchanging rules for the software
we're building everything is Up For
Debate but in the end it's still a fun
job it's worth the difficult part but I
think we need to be more honest and open
about the challenges we face it's
certainly not an easy job but it does
have its Great Moments